when it comes to hunting most Hawks like
flying solo except for the Harris's hawk
these desert Raptors love being part of
a crowd
especially when they move in for the
kill first
a scout takes the high ground scanning
the landscape with vision thought to be
eight times better than a human's then
it's time to invite the relatives over
for dinner
the first hog spots the quarry a
jackrabbit it won't be easy to catch
these hares wrote the book on evasive
action they can run as fast as 40 miles
an hour and leap ten feet but it may
take more than that to escape from the
wolf pack of the air
[Music]
the first hot flushes the Jackrabbit
while the others watch for the getaway
so when the rabbit instinctively zigzags
away from one predator it runs straight
into the talons of another and the whole
family gets to share in the spoils
though there's always a little sibling
rivalry but the family that prays
together will probably stay together so
long as they watch out for cactus thorns
[Music]